after a revamped map a new challenge
system were introduced last year
fortnight chapter 2 season 2 has now
launched with so much uncertainty
surrounding details about the season and
with the hints dropped from fortnight's
Twitter being well unhelpful to say the
least we dove into everything we could
as soon as season 2 went live and we
found the biggest changes so far the
agency is an all new faction that seems
to be the first step in a much longer
end game plan for Epic Games the spy
group consists of several agents that
players can unlock through for tonight's
battle pass and although these types of
seasonal rewards aren't new the specific
skins glider's banners and backstory of
these agents certainly are it seems to
be a mix of both characters we've grown
familiar with in the past like Lynx and
peely as well as agents we've never seen
before in any form providing an
interesting group of characters all
around
[Music]
henchmen are a new addition that
surround various parts of the new areas
on the map the rig the grotto the shark
the yacht and the agency are all
official named locations rather than the
smaller landmarks the rest of the map
will look familiar to players but these
additions change the overall look and
aesthetic of the map to fit a scene one
might expect in a spy movie
map changes are a huge thing that fans
look forward to with every update and
this time around you might think that
there aren't a large number of new areas
or a total overhaul due to the terrain
not changing significantly but in
addition to the new locations are these
hilarious areas that all seem to work in
tandem to fit the season's spy theme
telephone booths let you enter and
emerge with fortnight themed costumes
and disguises and allow you to
infiltrate areas that are always guarded
by enemy's henchman now guard specific
hideouts and for traces throughout the
map and can be defeated or even downed
but kept alive in order to use them to
pass by ID scanners in these areas the
addition of these enemies really do work
for the aesthetic of the season as well
as serving as a nice addition to the
weekly challenge lists to add on to the
fortresses that the henchmen are
guarding there are completely new
sources of loot in the form of locked
crates and secret vaults to gain access
to the vaults you need to find a
henchman boss in any guarded location
defeating a boss will give you a keycard
that will grant access to the secure
vaults there are also the locked crates
that require an ID scan to bypass their
security protocols two main ways have
been discovered already for players to
unlock these crates wearing any disguise
will let you pass an ID scan or you can
physically pick up a downed henchman and
have them scanned although you will
always definitely want to be mindful of
other battle royale players who might
easily be looking for their share of
hidden loot as well
one of the biggest surprises to kick off
the current season is the addition of
Deadpool the Merc with the mouth has
been revealed in the battle Past trailer
to be a secret skin although if you're
hoping to obtain the Deadpool skin soon
it seems like you'll have to wait for a
bit until something unlocks in the
season because it all seems time gated
right now however the new hub area has a
secret section that sharp-eyed players
will notice and if you follow the path
you'll see a ravaged bathroom with the
Avengers symbol and even a
tongue-in-cheek letter from Deadpool to
the epic games team a secret set of
Deadpool challenges can also be found
here as you log into an old computer
using Deadpool's username and password
shadow and ghost skins are a completely
new concept in season two since the
decision on which cosmetic you go for
has lasting consequences each agent has
a set of mission challenges for instance
the opening weeks set of challenges
involve the agent brutus and upon
completing his challenges there's a
shadow of ghost secret mission that you
can take part in allowing you to choose
which style you want your agent to have
the decision is permanent however and
it's not exactly clear just why
fortnight is preventing players from
having both types of cosmetics instead
having to decide on what feels like a
good versus evil faction this is
unprecedented for fortnight and one of
the biggest changes that seems like
it'll only develop more as the season
goes on this season is off to a fast
start as it shakes off the sluggish
extended tenure of season 1 and these
six changes are just the tip of the
iceberg as more agents will be unlocked
over the course of the next few weeks
and the trajectory of this season's
story becomes more clear if you're
excited for season 2 let us know why in
the comments below and be sure to check
with us every Thursday as we reveal all
the guides and gameplay playthroughs to
help solve even the most difficult
challenges in fortnight chapter 2 season
2
you